- Our next speaker is Edward Cooke,
Charles F Montgomery Professor
of the History of Art,
and Director of the Center of Study
in American Decorative
Arts and Material Culture.
As well as Professor of American Studies.
Professor Cooke focuses upon
American Material Culture
and Decorative Arts.
His books include
"Making Furniture in
Preindustrial America,"
"The Social Economy of Newtown
and Woodbury, Connecticut"
and "Inventing Boston Design,
Production and Consumption"
in the Atlantic world 1680 to 1720,
both of which focus upon the context
of craftsman client relations
in colonial North America.
He's also written extensively
on modern craft, historicizing
and extricating more
recent forms of production
and has been co-curator
and publication author
of six different exhibitions.
He is currently writing
"Global objects towards the
Connected sorry, Arts History."
Cooke's work in expanding
the field of decorative arts
has led to several awards
including the Iris Foundation Award
for Outstanding Contribution
to the Decorative Arts
the Furniture Society's
Award of Distinction,
election as an honorary fellow
of the American Craft Council
and College Art Association,
Distinguished Teacher
of Art History Award.
Please welcome professor Cooke.
(audience clapping)
- Thanks so much Matthew,
it's really nice to be
participating in this idea
of interdisciplinary
humanities to reassert
the fact that humanities
is not a dead kind of topic
and in an age of big data and
in different kinds of stem,
but actually thinking
can we look at humanities
in a expanded field in some ways,
and when I have started to
get into sort of dealing
with objects within an
art history department,
which used to be considered the minor arts
in the old slide library,
how do you make them
part of the real center
of a discipline like art history?
And one of the moves that I
felt like was really essential
is traditional art history
has been very ocular central.
That is it's all about the eye,
the eye and the mind and
it's visual analysis.
And sometimes you might describe it
as being object centered.
Some would even say object
or maybe art obsessed,
work of art obsessed.
And I wanted to flip that a little bit
and talk about object
driven kinds of inquiry.
In other words think about
objects from the inside out
rather than the outside in,
and sometimes not even
thinking about the end
of just sort of staying on the surface.
And so part of what I've
been about particularly
within last 10 years is developing a sense
of what I call material literacy
or maybe material intelligence,
that is knowledge of
materials and techniques
and how those can lead to
new and innovative questions.
And I think of this not as a substitute
for digital humanities but
actually it's complimentary
in terms of how we might open
up the idea of humanities
into a broader sensibility.
So one of the things that's really key
is to again, sort of
thinking about the stability
of materials and techniques
versus the permeability.
There's so many possibilities
of materials techniques
and what really leads to this idea
that I've developed in this new book
about interconnected art history.
It's not a linear path from A to B
but actually it's got
multiple layers directions
that are layered up on top of one another
to create this kind of rich mix.
So how do you go about teaching
from the inside out in some respects,
and part of this and Sue
Walker knows this well
in terms of my interest in
asking questions of materials,
that is, I was always struck by people
when I was doing my graduate work
who would just simply stay
true to ideas of style terms.
And to me, I always had questions,
why did somebody over theorize
the curving of a panel
in the denim Medfield Chess,
and talked about the
use of these compasses
to lay out all these different lines.
And I decided to do a carving exercise,
having never done something like this
and realized a compass is
used in four different areas
but that's it, the rest of
it is guided by the the curve
of the carving couch.
If you had the right four tools,
I could carve that in 20
minutes, light bulb goes off,
they over theorize it
without understanding
sort of from the inside out.
And so I did a number of projects
while I was writing my dissertation,
that I was asking
questions that had come up
in what I was studying,
what I was writing about.
So a great way to actually
write a dissertation,
making things at the same time.
It then continued on
as I tried to acquire,
not that I was gonna
become a full-time maker.
I had no illusions of this whatsoever,
but could I expose myself
to trying different things.
So doing a turning residency
down in Pennsylvania
for a week working with these
international turning stars
from France, from Australia,
from the United States,
learning some basics, be able
to make a series of objects
with each of them, so to
spending a day with each
of these international residents
and sort of working within
their vein, if you will.
And realizing contrary to
what most people thought,
a lay this not a industrial tool
that predetermines the result,
it's merely a tool and you
can use it in multiple ways.
I filed that trying glassblowing,
trying block printing,
everywhere I go and visit
makers throughout the world.
I'll try my hand at something.
I'll try hammering copper in Pune
and what you end up in here,
sort of like learning
to work on the ground
and learning to use your feet
using other parts of your body
as a way of biomechanic feedback
and how that affects the
work posture and counters.
It's kind of a Western
perspective on serious work,
you stand at a bench and you
sit upright the whole time
and you sort of over
jig some of your tools,
here working on the ground,
there are many different advantages
for certain types of work.
So it's this kind of
exploration that was so key
that I then wanted to
take into the classroom.
And one of the things
that's really such a
strength of teaching any kind
of art history at Yale
obviously is collections.
And it's not just the museums
themselves and what's on view,
but it's also what's in storage,
it's the conservation department,
the scientific research
department or IPCH,
these are all ways of thinking
about objects from the inside out,
and so when I teach classes,
what I'm also trying to do is say,
yes, visual analysis is
important but so it's touch.
So it's feeling the heft of
something, feeling surface,
being able to turn something
upside down, look inside that.
And so a lot of my courses
with the help of colleagues
at the art gallery have been,
I don't know any other university museum
that dedicate so much
space to study rooms,
and which you can bring
objects off of you,
and you can handle things.
You can pass them around many different.
I've been to a different gatherings.
And the Mellon Foundation has funded
in terms of trying to get museum people
and academics together.
And there's some people
who feel so excited
that they pass objects around in trays,
no touching but just
passing around in tray
and think that's education.
But it is, it's fear of
objects in some respects.
And what's wonderful is the
way in which colleagues here
work with you to establish
the right parameters,
to make this a safe endeavor,
to make sure that students are trained,
teaching fellows are trained
in how to handle objects,
how to model good behavior with objects
so that the students actually become
the most respectful kinds
of users of the collection.
They understand responsibility.
If you tell them about
it, you give it to them
you model it for them.
So this is just sort of,
what I do is I teach,
teaching fellows how to teach with objects
rather than, front of them
which I think is another really
important kind of maneuver.
And then they go ahead
and teach their students.
So what you're doing
is you're having effect
on two different generations of scholars,
but the graduate students,
we only had to teach with objects
as well as the undergraduates
exposure to kinds of questions
they could ask of objects
in terms of this kind
of global perspective.
And so here is it, you can
tell it's mask time from 2021.
And we are back in the classroom teaching.
This was the hardest
thing of course to teach,
object driven inquiry remotely.
We tried to get around it,
but there's nothing like the
satisfaction in that students,
you could tell not only
were they happy to be back
in the classroom together
but they also liked being
around objects yet again.
There are wonderful resources
not simply in central campus,
but west campus becomes a wonderful area
where you've got collection study centers,
the whole furniture study which
used to be on York Street,
it's out there and it
becomes this incredible lab
that's basically OpenStack storage
if you want to use a library
term that you can browse
that I actually run a first-year seminar
to get somebody early on in their career
and get people who are engineers,
who are art majors who
might be history majors,
quite a swath of people
who might take this course.
And we meet, that's the
classroom, the furniture study,
we go out in a shuttle every
week, one o'clock shuttle,
we're out there for two hours.
I can run class on the shuttle,
Roxanna was nice to
get a dedicated shuttle
so I could actually have Q and A
and some other kind of
housekeeping on the way out.
And then also be able to
teach graduate seminars
that would oftentimes
involve handling, looking,
talking about objects
with them right with us,
not just looking at images.
The Wurtele Study Center
where a lot of the collections
of non furniture materials
from American Decorative Arts
ceramics, glass, textiles et cetera.
It's an amazing, again open storage
but unlike the Luce center at the Met,
which is just encased
in captivity in Plexi,
this is all you can call
things and bring them out
for a particular class,
so with Denise Leidy,
who's the curator of Asian
art we ran a joint class
on Lacquer in a global context
not just East Asian lacquer,
but also Japanning from Europe and America
to talk about non-bond
export ware from Japan,
but handling things, looking at things,
asking questions at the objects
as we looked inside of them
was a critical part of it.
I've also tried to instead
of follow the principles
of John Dewey, learning by doing,
and what I try to do is is sort of,
put making exercises into
various different courses.
Initially in the old furniture study,
they had sort of a shop
and I would bring in a friend
of mine, Peter Follansbee
who used to be the joiner
at Plymouth Plantation
an open air museum up in Massachusetts.
And we worked out to the
different exercises we could do
within two hours to give students a chance
to split out greenwood, to play in it,
to learn how to do some
preliminary carving,
not to make something in its entirety,
but just get a few principles.
This is something that I've done,
carried forward as another
part of west campus.
Scott Strobel, when he
was head of west campus,
gave me a space out there to
use as a low tech maker space
that I could store some tools,
some materials out there,
and I've started to incorporate into this.
So that's where I've
done a woodworking now
on the left for a
first-year seminar in 2019,
I had another one class on
vessels in which one class,
we ended up hammering
copper disks into bowls
to learn something about hammering,
the malleability of metal.
This is again sort of greenwood-working
I did for this material literacy
and then embodied artisinal
knowledge using just basic tools
like clubs, froes, hatchets, and knives,
and sending people to work,
the advantage of fall in New England.
You can work outside.
So one year we were carving
spoons on west campus,
around the fire pit.
It wasn't available this year.
So we went to one of the
courtyards of west campus
in that collection study
center with a shaving horse.
Again, hatchets, froes,
splitting out wood,
green, moist wood and then working
on different spatulas and the like,
all this is working closely
with different kinds of artisans.
So Peter Follansbee, Andre
Garces was helpful with the wood,
Joan Parcher, a metal
smith up in Providence.
I've worked with her to developing
a very basic kit of tools
that I could give students to
work with making copper disks
learning how to shape something
with a ball-peen hammer on a steel block.
I worked with Andrew Hamilton
developing another session
on spinning and fiber.
And watching students get frustrated,
trying to use a drop spindle,
these very basic sorts of endeavors,
but you learn so much about the materials
and the feedback on them that
you can just see the ways
in which when you have
them students in class,
the way they get absorbed,
time flies for them.
I've also sent out kits,
ceramic kits, metal kits,
and weaving kits to students
for the undergraduate class
that they do in their own dorms.
This was a COVID related sort of endeavor.
And again, students just raved
about learning off screen
and being able to sort of learn
so much and then apply
what they've learned
in the grappling with the
material to their own work.
Again, with Andrew, we did some weaving.
This is some of the cardboard loom weaving
we did for the undergraduate,
just providing them with a cotton warp,
thread warp, cardboard
that sets up at the loom
and then a series of acrylics
that are sort of wool like,
so this is two different students' work
just completed this year.
I've worked with Mark Potter
to work on sort of different
sets of recipes for clay
that you can add different elements to it.
You can create different
sorts of appearances.
We did this exercise in
which we gave students
an hour in which they worked
with prescribed proportion
recipes to make something.
And then we gave them unlimited materials
and had them measure out.
These were the measuring devices they had,
just a piece of wood
with holes drilled in it.
So they had to work out
proportions in their minds
of what these materials were gonna do.
This is the kit of tools we used
to then work with either
regular clay, mixed
or we could start adding
different kinds of ingredients.
So they made their own recipe.
Once they made them, we
made them making test strips
to see, here are these different formulas
when they fired some of
them didn't do so well,
they shrunk, they bent around.
Some of them were not very stable
and some of them were disasters.
I feel like some of the
students didn't know
when you're baking for instance,
you do dry ingredients
first and then add liquid.
There was some people who did liquid first
and just peeled all the,
we were working on sheet rock
and it just like made a mess on the board.
So they were working on, you
learn a lot along the way.
And then these are just
some of the objects.
I had everybody do a
test strip in an object
with a given formula that they had to mix.
And then also with their own invention,
what I've done recently
for the undergraduates
is working with Penelope Van Grinsven,
who's taken on responsibility
of the five undergraduate pottery studios,
is to develop a kit that you could coil.
And this sort of has a
folding board with canvas,
a cutting wire two and a half pounds,
three pounds of clay,
a bucket with a sponge,
sort of a needle tool, a rib,
everything you need to
make objects like this,
these are not thrown on a wheel.
These are all coiled or slab construction.
These are undergraduates this past fall,
this semester who are
making these sorts of things
with this kind of exercise,
just given clay, a bending wheel
to sort of like the Lazy Susan,
just to get some sort of
sense of what's possible.
So in teaching material literacy,
Yale's got this incredible
opportunity in terms of access
to collections, things
that will inspire you,
ways to then try out
making yourself exposed
to different sorts of materials.
And then also taking that
knowledge back to the classroom,
looking, handling at objects,
not simply looking at
them under a vitrine.
And it's just a couple
things that are important
to this idea of the pedagogy of teaching
object-driven inquiry is in addition
to having objects study
classrooms in abundance.
And it's wonderful to see the Peabody
with their renovations
doing the same thing,
but to also start to realize,
well, if you can have a
messy space, can you design,
can you sort of work with
sympathetic knowledgeable makers?
Nobody, one person can do it all.
So oftentimes it's a
collaboration like to and fro-ing
with Joan Parcher, what
would be a good exercise?
What I'd tried the first time didn't work.
And that's when I got her
into the conversation.
These are things that I
was never trained in it,
but it's wonderful to sort of
develop these ideas together.
And then I think the other
thing that's important
is thinking about time
in terms of what can you
accomplish within two hours?
What's a project?
And so many Yale students
are perfectionists
who have an idea of what they wanna make.
And you have to get
them to shift that aside
and think, just go with a process,
don't worry about what you wanna exert
your will on something, what
can you learn along the way?
So it's been a fabulous
kind of path to go down
to thinking about the material
humanities in some respects,
and to thinking about what
Yale really allows us to do.
And I hope that you get
a chance to sort of visit
with some of the other information tables
from the, just thinking
of the Wurtele Center
and the art gallery study centers
in west campus of the IPCH
Institute for Preservation
of Cultural Heritage
and the research scientists there,
conservation staff for
the various museums.
It's this kind of package that you've got
so many people you can turn to,
to ask questions and to work
together to sort of move
some of this project forward.
So I'm happy to answer questions.
I just want to sort of tempt you
in terms of what's possible.
(audience clapping)
- [Student] I'm happy to start off.
So when we were talking
about the digital humanities,
the question of sort of the skills,
the coding skills and
whatnot that are needed
are not sort of part of the
curriculum that we understand.
Are there ways in which you
can see this sort of work
being incorporated into the
curriculum or how you've.
- Yeah, I mean, what I've managed to do,
the question is how to integrate
this into the curriculum.
And that's why I wanted to actually show
what I've been doing
in some of the classes.
So with the undergraduates
I haven't necessarily
other than the furniture class,
I haven't taught them
in class time itself,
but I developed these kits last year
when people were remote,
that actually had them
pick up or mail to them,
if they were truly off campus
and they would make things,
photograph them and then ship the kit.
Well, the weaving kit was inexpensive.
So that was just a throw
away but the the ceramic kit
and the metal kit ended up investing
25 to $35 for each of those kits.
So that's a way in which
I felt like that became
an assignment, making and reflecting
and really giving them parameters
in which they could succeed.
And they had to write
reflections, as I said,
so it's not just simply winging it
and then that's the end of it.
But by reflecting and giving them,
prompting them with certain questions
was a way to dig deeper
into what this meant
in terms of the course.
For the graduate students
I do it within class
because you've got a
longer period of time.
And I will try to develop say
three or four making exercises
over the semester.
So this course I'm teaching
now on embodied knowledge,
we did woodworking first
and the emphasis there
was on the materials.
What does the material, what's
the agency of the material?
Cause it's greenwood
and it's gonna go the way it wants to go.
So you have to work with it
and then when we did metal,
it was about thinking about the body
'cause I had them working
at a bench on the ground,
sitting all sorts of, just kept
moving their body positions
around to get them finding
what's the right way.
And again, they had to write reflections
and then we just did pottery on Wednesday.
And there I was trying
to get them to focus
on the hand and again,
having them on the ground
at a wheel coiling all sorts
of different movements.
So there's a way to do
it, to incorporate it.
And then there's also
like the undergraduates
have this opportunity in
the residential colleges,
that there are a number
of different studios,
like five pottery studios.
There's a weaving studio
in Morrison styles,
but it's harder for the graduate students
to gain access to that.
But it's not, I'm not running
an art school course either.
So it's that fine line,
It's got a tie into
the theme, the reading,
the intellectual content
of the course, yeah there.
- [Student] I have two questions one is,
I was wondering if you (indistinct)
but I was also wondering if you
still teach this to faculty.
- I have, there've been a couple of times
that I had the opportunity to
have a teaching on west campus
that was designed for
graduate students faculty
and museum people.
And it had different themes
and brought different people
in to run different sorts of projects.
So one was on this idea of spoons.
I mean, we sort of have a
session which we had makers,
artists talk about their
practice sort of one day,
a second day would be making
things on west campus.
And the third day would be
about exhibition practice.
So there was one year we did
one that had sort of the idea
of reproducibility that we had spoons.
We cast spoons, we curve
spoons, we made clay spoons,
we hammered copper spoons
and just kept rotating people
around, always working
with the same spoon.
And yet also had Andres Garces
who was working in
conservation at that point,
he had scanned one of these spoons.
And then we did 3D
printing as well as CNC,
subtractive technology in wood,
and started working off
of what's the difference
between a cast pewter spoon
and a CNC cut out spoon
or a 3D printed spoon.
And it was great conversations
just to sort of explode that,
there was another year
we talked about the idea
of repair and different kinds
of recalibration that we had.
Christina Kim who's a textile artist,
come in and talk about in a sewing circle.
We had Sam Thomas hard-sunny
beater who came in
and we had a beating exercise
to talk about reconciliation
that he's been doing with the
Canadian boarding schools,
indigenous people and
it was just incredible
to think about reconciliation, repair
and how making and materials
really lend themselves
to this easygoing conversation.
So that's been one thing it's
hard to do it every year.
Sort of just coming up with these ideas,
trying to mobilize people,
I think in terms of
stories, anecdotes of it's.
I mean what I've really been struck by
with a graduate seminar
than when we're working
with different materials,
watching people all of a sudden just relax
and start to realize I don't
have to be a perfectionist.
I'm just, I'm going with
the flow, the idea flow.
And one of the topics
that's come up this year
is what does focus mean,
what is concentration?
What does absorption and how
can you be focused in an area
where you're all hammering
and all of a sudden like that,
that white noise starts to become
a way that you create
your own little bubble
versus being outdoors
on a beautiful fall day.
And you're just using a
simple little slide knife
doing your final cuts on a spatula
and you're just, you're
completely removed from the world.
So it's interesting
to just sort of watching
people's bodies relax,
watching when they're
social with one another,
when they're sort of
looking at their own work
and you start to see
how it affects the way
in which they're talking about objects
in subsequent classes.
I don't know if that answers
some of your question.
Thanks Cindy.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)